hello Johnny yes so Charlie yes so
Charlie is so cool
today is Sunday yesterday was Saturday
and that was the day of the UK YouTube
gathering fortunately because I don't
have a camera I get to tell you what
happened through the medium of vlogging
yay the day started off pretty badly
my train was delayed and then cancelled
so I had to go on a different train
which was then delayed and then me and
miles got a car and started driving off
to London we got into London and and
spent absolutely ages trying to find a
place to park but and we ended up
turning up about an hour and a half late
which is annoying because what happened
as soon as we got there is we got
swamped I'll just show you using a
gameboy advance what happening hey it's
Charlie Charlie okay so I'm just kind of
like I went to wagamama obviously it's
not as good as the room that I have in
mind town but still pretty good
we also went out and bought some Percy
pigs obviously and had to sign some
thirsty pigs for people even though I
don't have a signature I'm just gonna
rip my name on a few things I was
signing 30 pigs and shoes and someone's
guitar as well so anyway after we went
to get the 30 pigs we then went to a big
arcade which used to be like a savior
place I went on the dodgems with Pierre
file and got a headache I went on Mario
Kart the arcade mario kart with Nariman
which is pretty cool even though I lost
but it was still cool game
we both got bit here by the computer day
and he only had a very place when so
after like the craziness of the arcades
and all that noise and headaches and
stuff like that I'm gonna sure get away
with paper barriers and go to a coffee
shop we had a nice little chat but she
still hasn't unblocked me on our set I
brought my karela mask as well but I
just got pooed on by a bird and I had
nothing else to wipe off the poo so I
used quicker elements
never got pooed on as well so I had to
wipe off his poo with my gorilla mask
yes oh I don't really wear that mask
much better odds people was a good thing
was lots of things happened there were
big mesh of things that came together
very nicely
mm-hmm when um a sentence there Zelda
this is when a contact signs on this is
when I get an initial message from
somebody this is what happens when I
connect to MSN
and this is when I disconnect because I
have magic lighting footage of the day
I'll tell you the way to go to find
fridge this is going to be a video
response to Myles this video all of the
videos of the London gathering are going
to be responses to that video I'm really
good it's now but this is where the
video responses this is where the video
description is and nothing's over
nothing's over there yeah I'm rambling
and rambling don't ramble channeling it
yeah so thanks that's pretty good
you